[Applauso]
c'è un cristiano non può manco soffiarsi
il naso inizio video che questo tira
fuori la mappa di di one piece ma tutti
ragazzi e benvenuto che sono video sono
fa vj oggi siamo su ok siamo su bebè
vapor ma poiché non è un gioco di vapore
cos'è sto schifo via di nominare un po
che non si sa come ovviamente come
diavolo siamo arrivati qua ma non ho
capito ma anche dove stiamo andando e
perché ci stiamo andando processo beh
bella questa torcia mi piace molto
complimenti per il design che ragazzi la
mappa del malandrino la mappa del
malandrino mai fare incazzare dei libri
di testo ragazzi perché ti ti ti mandano
a fuoco tutti ok sono diventato dalla
torcia umana senza un apparente motivo
c'è un libro mi ha trasformato in una
specie di fiammifero ambulante per ogni
nostro capendo sto gioco siam partiti ma
non lo sto capire cos'è però a dio
picchio più piccoli bari di questo il
mio bello ho sempre sognato di picchiare
i barili tirare calci alle cose
io che cosa cazzo fatto ragazza è vero
sono fiammifero ambulante piacere sono
ma che cazzo ti segue questa come ti
permetti lui ma da una volta sei brutto
profitto su marco longo latte che bello
vabbè amico mio sei fattelo dire sei
veramente la cosa più bella che abbia
mai visto in tutta la mia vita lui è qui
8 di me comunque zio a parte gli scherzi
posso tipo saltarti sulla testa così
allora che scontro senza eguali
rocky balboa e morto ecco ben non ho
capito bene anche come dovuto girare il
problema di tre se come che ne so io
eddy cue di grazia è potuto fuori
governo senza neanche ucciderlo però non
ci sarebbe stato gusto più che ragazzi
se vedete una persona che va a fuoco in
giro sono io che avevo freddo e non può
riscaldare l'ambiente ragazze non
intanto trovarobe sono anche dove cazzo
stone calami nota hai rotto il cazzo
devo abbaio devo abbassare il volume i
ficazione giorni dà fastidio quando mi
sfruttando avanti mimì mi scoppia il
cervello si gente che si sia gobbi cosa
fanno non sai zio bobbies è un figo
della madonna che passa dai vai
tranquillo tranquillo vai tranquillo
ragnatele meravigliose miss puntando i
ragni gli ammazzo
giuliano amato chi ha fatto il gioco noi
a fare qui
oh mio dio con il puzzle è cagato la
crisi non è che potete puntarmi così
come la mer gestite store anziché uno
schifo hai rotto le palle
si può regalare ancora chi è vabbè se
vuoi invitare anche tua zia facciamo un
party vado a prendere tipo un po da con
può dare con le ci divertiamo se
vogliano è stato divertendo a seriamente
zio mobili o blocchi cosa fai qui è
diventato più bello le solite adesso hai
un tuo stile zio mie mani così è non
cambiare mai bello che in sto gioco non
si vedrebbe un cazzo sono io che mi
faccio luce da solo perché mondo andarsi
a fuoco non vedrai una mazza era che
faccia facciamo after qua dentro che mi
sembra una zona da parti una porta
soppiantato una porta qua sotto cena
spiegatemelo ci aprì la porta con la
maniglia sei un [ __ ] bordello
bordello che casino che è qua dentro ma
cosa devo fare c'è ragazzi
sentite cosa che cazzo la candela più
bella che abbia mai visto da perdere che
mai tanto ci sono dei cervelli
[Musica]
cosa ho sbloccato fatemi capite melo
prima che io vada bravo perfetto e bobby
contro la mite chiappe che devo andare
avanti a vedere che si no
non devi chiudere le porte di
controllarvi le chiappe basta che mi
distrugge l'animo ancora a bello del sì
ma fate un parrucchino e non è che una
donna che sentite è siete veramente la
cosa più bella che abbia mai visto ma
non sarà un dentista un parrucchiere
passate anche da kiko via giusta madonna
che cartella temi toglierti proprio
dalla vita perfetta solo becco in giro
madonna agli schiaffi andare a fare la
spesa quel lurido cosa mi spunta davanti
così c'è una ok ho fatto casino non
volevo è una specie di palla da disco
solo un po più moderna alfredo schiavi
proprio ma [ __ ] la facciamo così
ragazzi
mettetevi importa che giochiamo a calcio
parlano quale eccolo di perfetto
la rotta lui è a sti cazzi del
peperoncino zio dove hai mangiato di
così piccante fammi capire l'altro io io
ho un terzo braccio regala un terzo
bravo ma come o tre braccia ma il
risultato va beh dai non è possibile è
forte ci sono i sto giorgio cos'è
permesso devo trovare io a salve ascolti
e non vorrei disturbarla però devo
vedere un ucciso la povera che sono
bastardi e lei che è qui da molto più
tempo di me di sicuro lo sa comunque a
parte tutto devo uscire di qua si può
grazie zia sconta un attimo fammi un
favore tieni sta roba perché non ho
capito cosa dura qualche a puzzare
spuntato un coso e sfrutta cosacco e
quanto siano cantate da dio ragazzi
quando eretto dai suoi
esatto è proprio così fa la canzone dei
ragni con la testa che sono contento di
scoprire nuovi esemplari di schifo ogni
giorno che passa veramente grazie mille
cristo qualcuno ha qualche spiegazione
per questa cosa ma di quella a minchia
andiamo avanti lo finiamo questo gioco
per cortesia alla porta 2 ed i teloni
che come che si fa come si tirava fuori
sta roba così
dai dai e questo ce l'ho ce l'ho
apt apriti sesamo apriti sedano a bravo
sei il figlio di zio bobbit per caso ma
mi sapete poi galatro miac la devo fare
ma [ __ ] vapor demo non ho mai
giocato alla roba più bella di questa
non so come ho fatto a farmela scappare
fino adesso ragazzi
ok era figo ma il senso ha tutto questo
dove cazzo sta comunque ragazzi questo è
una demo il gioco ufficiale uscirà tipo
un mesetto fatemi sapere se volete che
io lo faccia ma no proprio no no due le
no no per scrivere no intanto mi fa
schifo perché penso che ci siano dei
ragni con la testa che girano anche
adesso mi sognerò sta roba c'è comunque
ragazzi a parte tutto spero che vi do vi
sia piaciuto è stato alquanto strano per
ogni mi piace che mettete un ragno in
meno con la testa in giro per il mondo
che fanno comodo quindi ragazzi spero
che vi sia piaciuto e come al solito sul
video vi è piaciuto lasciato momento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook che
covano i video trovate la descrizione
sensori si discute ci vediamo al
prossimo video e la ragazza
[Musica]